yes vaccines do you harm people by the  way so I just found out something when I  was on lunch and I want to show it to  you you were talking about Dr Ten  Penny's testimony about magnetic vaccine  crystals so this is what I found out so  I have a key and a bobby pin here  explain to me why the key sticks to me  it sticks to my neck too  I got those  yeah so if somebody can explain this  that would be great  any questions  so a few things here first of all when  the key sort of sticks to her chest the  chest is slightly angled and because of  the material of the key and surface  tension and if she hasn't showered if  she's slightly sweaty the key could  stick there for a moment it doesn't mean  that that there's anything magnetized  there then it fails on her neck it just  Falls right off